[Musique]
voilà renforts arrivés ils le teuton
patron alan descend vite chez tes amis
tu te proposera un moment ça te fera du
bien oh oui parce que ce soir je veux
sans tout barbouillé
en effet le à tout à leur patron à tout
à l'heure nous nous sommes bons
[Musique]
et voilà suite tout propre et moi aussi
bon soit là mais je voudrais bien pas
petit verdot
je suis un petit bonhomme et bientôt
pour notre nom ce qui a sûrement manger
trop niais juste un petit mois nous
c'est de l'eau qui piquent 7 fera du
bien et
[Musique]
ce qu'elle si les enfants
je me sens maintenant ferme les yeux
nous et ne regardent pas mou long on a
préparé un beau jus qu'on va faire avec
toi ça y est regarde
momo le tronc oui il faut chaque à tagro
moi je prends la drôme c'est moi la
petite on joue la petite chaque à une
gêne et toi mon amour tu joue de la
trompette et nous enchante pre 2 et 3
c'est la trompette qu'on attend
quand je l'entends je suis content s'il
a fait tomber sa muse et nous nous nous
accompagner pour monter ce n'est le plus
joli manège ou remonter sur les chevaux
de bois
on irait jouer aux anneaux on regardera
le loto on rencontrera des amis
qui sommes nous aurons de hocine nous
l'ancien chouchou de grogne aussi c'est
une chaussure jetée pu nous garde argent
sera fatigué
on va se reposer
tous les jeunes après la dig et en y
habitait se coucher c'est maintenant on
va se coucher tu sais cette chanson on
la chante quand on va au jardin propos
je les bons coups elle est très amusant
et une autre est bien la trompette
nounours j'ai l'oreille musicale le vent
en la jette à lier à temps
bonne nuit joueur de trompette à demain
nicolas d'un bien ta première fête comme
no2 petit ami nicolas et pimprenelle
amusez-vous à chanter une jolie chanson
et allez vite vous coucher les enfants
on s'est bien amusés pas trop tu en as
une belle trompette nounours vous voulez
me prendre je t'ai entendu tu joue très
bien
hop hop hop hop hop on le trouve toute
une autopompe pompon quand je l'entends
je suis content la nuit des enfants fait
debout rêve allons en route trompettiste
au pub peau
[Musique]